prénommé garbin bonjour merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france alors
nous venons de le dire des spécialistes
elle s'interroge sur l'effet contre
productif de du fait de tester les gens
trop de dépistage tue-t-il le dépistage
selon vous oui il est possible
effectivement en raison de la limitation
d'accès aux tests et du délai pour
obtenir le résultat qu'effectivement le
dépistage plus massif soit pas optimale
effectivement si on obtient son résultat
plusieurs jours après le contact
potentiellement contaminants et qu'entre
temps on ne sait pas isolé et bien on
continue à diffuser le virus dans la
communauté et donc effectivement très
probablement il faut opter désormais
pour des tests plus rapide est également
probablement hiérarchiser les
indications pour permettre le dépistage
rapide des personnes symptomatique et
contacts al'inverse des sujets qui
demande un dépistage plus pour confort
ou pour se rassurer
justement olivier véran le ministre la
santé a parlé de tests anti génique des
tests qui délivre des résultats assez
rapide justement aux 15 20 minutes
quelle est la fiabilité de ces tests
alors ce sont des tests qui sont très
probablement moins fiables que les tests
virologiques classique c'est-à-dire par
rt pcr
on estime probablement qu'ils sont 15 à
20% moins fiables donc effectivement si
vous êtes très fortement suspect d'être
porteurs du virus c'est-à-dire vous est
symptomatique et où vous avez été
contact proche d'un patient contaminé et
que ce type de test est négatif il
faudra le confirmer par un test
classique par rt pcr l' avantage de cet
instant tigenix et qu'ils sont plus
rapides vous avez le résultat en 20
minutes
donc effectivement ceci sera utile
pour permettre une stratégie plus
efficace d'isolement et plus et pour
permettre aux personnes plus rapidement
de savoir leur statut là on a
l'impression quand même que les français
font plus confiance aux tests pcr
aujourd'hui ils sont accessibles à tout
le monde parfois même gratuit on voit
dès que justement dans les centres d
analyse comment faire pour pas que ces
centres soient complètement plein est ce
qu'aujourd'hui il faudrait plus sans
changer de stratégie est justement basée
plus sur le risque que sur le volume et
ne pas laisser les gens se testait à
tout va alors tout d'abord effectivement
ces tests antigénique dont on parle
seront accessibles dans les laboratoires
donc effectivement une personne qui va
se présenter dans un laboratoire pour
faire un test de dépistage
eh bien on aura le choix entre le test
par pcr et le test antigénique et très
probablement les autorités de santé
devront faire un certain nombre de
recommandations pour savoir si le
biologiste choisir à tel ou tel test en
fonction de la situation du patient des
indications médicales
par ailleurs effectivement très
probablement il faut séparer les
demandes entre celles qui sont très
urgente c'est à dire des patients
symptomatiques ou contactez de sujets
porteurs démontrer versus les demandes
un peu moins urgents qui sont des
demandes administratives par exemple
pour voyages ou des demandes de confort
ou d'inquiétude pour la personne puisque
aujourd'hui le dépistage est accessible
sans ordonnance et donc au choix
directement du patient alors j'aimerais
que l'on revienne à un petit peu sur les
chiffres du coup vie d'un de ces
dernières 24 heures une augmentation qui
inquiète un petit peu justement la
direction générale de la santé 6544
nouveaux cas on sait qu'il ya
aujourd'hui 71
91 91 nouveaux foyers de contamination
qui ont été détectés 588 personnes sont
toujours actuellement prises en charge
dans les services de réanimation c'est
sans 450 de plus qu'il ya une semaine
est ce que ces chiffres vous inquiète
selon alors ce sont des chiffres ce sont
des chiffres qui attire la vigilance et
la prudence effectivement depuis
maintenant une dizaine de jours on
assiste à une augmentation régulière et
significative du nombre d'admissions en
réanimation
alors ce sont des personnes qui ont le
même profil de vulnérabilité que celle
que l'on a pu au cours du pic épidémique
en mars avril probablement ces personnes
sont aujourd'hui un peu moins grave donc
à peu près deux tiers d'entre elles ne
sont pas sous ventilation artificielle
néanmoins victimes en les chiffres sont
en augmentation et pour éviter toute
saturation des services de réanimation
et pour nous permettre de prendre en
charge également l'ensemble des autres
pathologies chez les personnes covin
négatif il faut absolument et très
rapidement mieux contrôler la diffusion
de virus dans la communauté grâce à une
meilleure application des mesures
barrières un port du masque systématique
dans les lieux clos et dans les lieux
ouverts là où il est exigé dernière
question très rapidement à quoi doit-on
s'attendre ces prochaines semaines alors
très probablement en raison du décalage
qui existe entre la contamination et le
développement de la maladie et notamment
des formes graves il faut on va assister
à une encore une poursuite de
l'augmentation des admissions à
l'hôpital est en réanimation mais on
espère effectivement que cette que cette
augmentation va finir par plafonner et
va se stabiliser un plateau probablement
pas très élevé qui nous permettra en
toute sécurité de prendre en charge les
patients infectés par le cos vide et
notamment en réanimation de traiter les
formes graves car désormais nous avons
de meilleur
moyens de prise en charge avec les
sports évidemment de réduire le taux de
décès merci beaucoup
bruno m'égare ban d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes chef
de service à l'hôpital lariboisière à
paris